police patrolling the streets of Beijing
by night
it's a far cry from scenes in the
Chinese Capital just the day before
the government has increased Security in
several major cities following the
biggest protests in decades in Shanghai
scuffles broke out when police officers
demanded people delete images from their
phones
are not filming anymore this woman is
saying authorities are keeping tight
control of what's spreading on social
media they don't want people to see that
there are other people who are you know
courageous enough to go to the street to
protests barricades now line the streets
where hundreds of people had gathered
before calling for an end to strict
lockdowns quarantines Mass testing and
disruptions that have been enforced for
three years reports quoting
demonstrators say authorities have
opened inquiries into the events of the
past few days and have been summoning
people suspected of attending protests
to give written statements detailing
their activities
many people had used the demonstrations
to speak out about a range of grievances
including censorship and diminishing
civil liberties
despite the challenge to the Chinese
government analysts doubt it'll Force
any change people can go to the street
uh some spontaneously to voice their
discontent to demand it for Freedom uh
you know but for any kind of movement to
sustain you need an organizing structure
you need a civil society groups you need
activists but those people are gone they
are in jail they are silenced or they're
in Exile and a media briefing on Tuesday
Health officials did say they would
address concerns about excessive
controls and fine-tune regulations to
limit the impact on livelihoods but they
stop short of conceding there was a
problem with the zero covert policy
some citizens and the general public say
the biggest problem is the
oversimplification of the prevention
control measures the arbitrary
imposition of restrictions and a
one-size-fits-all approach it's not the
first time the government has
acknowledged public frustrations in the
past though nothing has changed which
suggests it could be some time before
China reconsiders its response to the
pandemic Patrick fock Al Jazeera Hong
Kong